sections 31 TV movie will be on
Paramount plus by the end of this year
filming begins in just a couple of weeks
and it's not being done as a big
cinematic movie it is actually being
done more of a long episode really so
yeah it'll be on our screens by the end
of this year Strange New World season 3
will be on our screens also by the end
of 2024 but it's probably only going to
be the first few episodes this is
something that's probably going to
either maybe have a release of the first
five episodes before Christmas and then
five episodes just after um but they
will be pretty much ready to go by the
end of 2024 or it'll be early 2025 at
the latest Star Trek Legacy I am
predicting the Star Trek Legacy will be
announced in 2024 I have always argued
that I think Star Trek Legacy was
planned from day one I actually think
Paramount are doing exactly the same as
what they did with strange new worlds
I'm told strange new worlds was planned
from day one as soon as they brought
Pike into discovery